(holiday music)
- Oh, it must be nice to
come home from college
to see your family, eh, kiddo?
- Uh, yeah it's nice.
Listen, I'm only here to sleep late
and have mom do my laundry, alright?
- You know, this country's
going down the crapper.
I was watching the news yesterday,
and they got these weirdos...
- Mmm, that turkey
smells good, hey grandpa?
I'm changing the subject before
you say something super racist.
- Sweetheart, did you want
to bring some leftovers home?
- Oh! Sure, if you have any.
Give me any food you have!
I eat Hot Pockets for every meal!
- So, what's new with you?
Are you seeing anyone?
I bet you are.
- Yeah I am, she's pretty great.
We've talked on OkCupid four times?
- I just want to say from
the bottom of my heart
I love having you here, Merry Christmas.
Get the hell out of my house
and don't come back for a year!
(holiday music)